und deshalb haben wir den Londoner
Zugfahrer abgeklatscht wir sind auf dem
Weg nach London der Flug hat erstmal
eine Stunde Verspätung dann habe ich mir
eine richtig teure Cola gegönnt 3,30 €
für kalten Genuss und diese Aussicht
okay es hat sich schon gelohnt dann habe
ich auch noch meine airpods vergessen
und musste mit Hansa One Piece gucken
angekommen in London gebe ich euch jetzt
den besten Tipp für Bahn und Zugfahrten
ihr braucht keinen trendticket kaufen
nutzt dafür einfach Apple pay oder das
was sie auf dem Handy habt aber vergesst
nicht euch auch immer auszustempeln
sonst wird's teuer mitten auf der
Strecke sind wir dann gestrandet und
eine Stunde hat sich nichts bewegt bis
der Zugfahrer dann endlich weiterfahren
konnte
[Applaus]